I remember early in your career after
Chris Farley died it was the rap always
was well spades not gonna be able to do
anything without Chris Farley he needs
Charlie needs Farley right that's tell
me is that still the right I mean I hear
it on Twitter yeah told you damn it
didn't make any sense but you were like
yeah well you're like hmm what a great
comedy team you guys were do you still
think about it at all or you just sort
of passed it overall I do think that uh
it was a big waste of course I mean I
could we could have done at least I had
a career doing horrible movies with him
when we were both done you know I mean
we just keep coming back and like hey we
got you better had a freak you out it I
mean you've gone on to great success
who's the jeans I figured that YouTube
guys would be good in the first movie
who was Lorne
he told two writers that write a movie
about these guys the way they act around
the office like spades like the fake
smart one and Farley walks behind him
and ask some questions and then I make
fun of them and then it's sort of like
The Three Stooges cut ya know was
smarter than the other yeah fake smarter
and then uh but I was always like in awe
that he was so good and almost didn't
know it so even in movies like Tommy Boy
I'm remembering bits and pieces he would
say over the weeks and just go this
actually one line we got to work in
because you said it two weeks ago or fat
guy in a little coat let's let's try to
put that in the movie somewhere even
though it's so dumb but I think people
think it's funny if we do and I like
some of the funny stories about Farley
cuz the one that I had never heard
before never heard you tell before that
Farley managed today one of Lorne
Michaels beautiful assistants he loses
her and it turns out that Chris lost her
to a comedian and you try to console him
and what did you say to him when he lost
this I think it was me and Sandler were
with him and uh and he comes back just
she comes crawling back yet and I don't
think so
and he goes her she's got some new boy
toy and I go yeah and he goes well
because he's all cocky now he's killing
on the show goes well might be
better-looking to me but he ain't richer
he ain't funnier and he's not more
famous and we were just dead silent
and we're like over three it's uh Steve
Martin she was dating Steve shut the
[ __ ] up Richard Farley could be
viciously mean you point out at his
story that you were dating a girl who I
guess was in Playboy and you right that
wasn't really mean that come on that's I
mean it's funny mean he takes the
magazine and does what yeah I went I
dated a girl from briefly like that was
in Playboy and I couldn't believe it so
of course I was bragging right at work I
have a little tiny office with Farley
and yeah Adam and Chris Rock I've got
one you walk through my tiny one huh so
we're all jammed in there I go to read
through and Farley goes he writes me a
note and throws it over and he's just
staring at me he goes it says David did
you go in the office yet and I go I look
over I go we just came out of the office
he goes go in and I go okay whatever and
then it he gets closer to read to the
break and read through he looked so when
he goes go he's mouthing it and laughing
and rubbing his hands I go alright
whatever so I get up to go and and he
has the playboy out and he jacked off
all over it there's jizz all over that
is disgusting but it's funny it's so
funny I go wait what yeah he was out of
his [ __ ] man out of his mind by the
way on the way to read through which we
had probably a minute after we walked
out of there while he did it oh my god
because I can come in under a minute I
go really what about when you were the
girl goes who is a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm stoned
Zor you you ever watch the old movies or
the too painful I mean there aren't so
much that you get caught up in them and
it's sort of sad and fun because you
remember the whole day of the shoot you
remember right one day going let's bring
a little clip-on tie and say it's a
clip-on and you go oh really
and then we go let's just try to put
that in somewhere in the scene because
you'd see that mini sides for the next
day and go this feels a little flat like
housekeeping from Tommy Boy I would do
every morning when I came to his room
I'd go house and he go and he goes the
[ __ ] out here put that [ __ ] thing on
the door and I go housekeeping he goes
god damn it and he'd open the door oh
it's you when you do that stuff in real
life and it's funny yeah and you go to
try it on film you don't know for sure
and stuff we do anyway we go if it's
done right I think people will think
it's funny too I think what works about
us if we're so different but it also can
get to be trouble what it's a great
friend of mine pretty funny like a team
aren't you
Chris and I are the fatty and skinny the
90s